let's talk more about the election and
the economy with the top Republican in
the house Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy
he joins us live from Bakersfield
California leader McCarthy it's great to
have you well thanks for having me on
Mike I appreciate it your observations
of how Vice President Biden has hailed
these attacks and the surge of your
California Senator Kamala Harris well I
don't think Joe Biden's going to become
the nominee not for this not for this
position but for many positions going
forward he's got a long history I think
his timing is wrong and I just do not
believe he'll be the nominee I'll be I
believe there will be others who come up
and there's going to be a lot of
opportunity
I actually think Bernie Sanders has the
best chance of becoming the nominee
because where this democrat party has
moved it's no longer the Democrat Party
it's become the socialist Democrat Party
and Bernie Sanders has the the best
philosophy because he was registered as
socialist to represent the current party
as you travel the country in your
leadership position and your district
back home in California what's your
assessment of the state of the US
economy well you could look at it we're
the strongest we've ever been just say
this month alone June the best we've
ever had in the market in 80 years
unemployment and it cuts across all ages
all demographics the strongest we've
ever seen even the Democrats if you
looked at that Bloomberg poll just a
couple days ago the sentiment for the
economy is the strongest with Democrats
since 2001 that's stronger than at any
time when President Obama was in office
and a lot of that credit of a majority
of all that credit goes to this
president
remember what President Obama said the
idea of getting 3% growth you need a
magic wand all we really needed was
somebody in office who understood how to
make jobs how to make America stronger
and really put America first through
regulation through tax reform and all
the other things this president's been
able to accomplish not even taking into
account what he accomplished last week
at g20 and over in North Korea those are
historical times and I think that is
what's going to help propel this
president to re-election well let's do a
little more on foreign policy first
president Trump's historic moment
crossing into North Korea for Vice
President Joe Biden and some 2020 Dems
have called
photo op are they wrong about that there
they are really wrong about this because
think for one moment and if you study
history we had a real challenge with the
Silvia Union you had Ronald Reagan
president at a time to travel to the
Sylvia Union you had President Reagan's
step away from the negotiations in
Iceland with Gorbachev because it wasn't
getting everything that we needed and
you know what happened at the end of the
day the Berlin wall collapsed and so did
the Sylvia Union now compare that to
today's challenge where he had North
Korea testing long-range nuclear
missiles that's no longer the case are
they testing those you had President
Trump step away from the table in
Vietnam because it wasn't at the right
setting but what happened with President
Trump he reset the terms to have a
negotiation now in two to three weeks we
will be talking about denuclearizing
North Korea
we are safe for today based upon what
President Trump has been able to do and
build and when you looked at Kim
jong-un's face you saw a smile there
you've got to build trust before you
could ever get to an agreement that's
exactly what President Reagan did with
the Sylvia Union and Gorbachev and you
saw the results and the president Trump
is correct in this and history will
prove that on China Senator Marco Rubio
is expressing serious concern tweeting
over the weekend quote if President
Trump has agreed to reverse recent
sanctions against Huawei he has made a
catastrophic mistake it will destroy the
credibility of his administration's
warnings about the threat posed by the
company no one will ever again take them
seriously I want to get your thoughts on
that I have real concerns about wall way
but remember what the president said he
said he'll deal with that the end of the
negotiation this president has been very
strong against wall way we know the
challenge is what they have the number
of backdoors we know what this president
has done talking to our allies if they
if they bring in wall weigh products we
can no longer share with them
information because it'll go directly
back to China
remember what China does China has to
have the Communist Party in every
company their government part-owned of
wall way this is a real concern from a
security issue long-term and I think
we've got to let this president he
understands this I've talked to him I
even talked to the
today he called we're talking about the
border I know where this president
stands when it comes to the security of
this nation and he will stand firm
against wall way before you and your
colleagues left town you passed a 4.6
billion dollar humanitarian aid package
negotiated by democrat senator patrick
leahy and republican senator richard
shelby but it appears it severely
divided the House Democratic caucus take
a listen they will remember that we
caged them up like animals we ripped
them away from their parents and pumped
them with drugs to make them stop crying
for their mothers no amount of apologies
or no amount of debating in this chamber
will make it better madam Speaker it
will not be the end of this debate it
will be the battle cry it will be the
battle cries how big of a problem does
Speaker Nancy Pelosi have in her hands
right now she has a severe problem
because if you watch this debate it
lasted more than 58 days since President
Trump had requested supplemental funding
for the aide along this border even the
New York Times wrote two editorials
about it Mexico sent 15,000 troops to
the southern end of their border
everyone understands there's a crisis
even the Senate Democrat senators on the
Senate side understand it but not in the
house you know a bill came out of the
Senate 84 to 8 every Democrat in the in
the leadership on the Senate side voted
for it but Nancy Pelosi did not want to
bring that up you know why because she
believes in open borders she won deny
anybody working along the border to get
that they could not have overtime in a
time where you just had a hundred and
forty-four thousand apprehensions of
people illegally crossing just last
month something we have not seen in a
decade this is when I talk about this is
not the same Democratic Party of the
past this is a new socialist Democratic
Party and many of the members there call
themselves that and they are the new
leaders of this socialist Democratic
Party and that's a real concern not only
do they want to have open borders they
want to allow illegals to even vote we
had a we had a vote on the floor about
illegals from another countries touching
ballots they voted that down leader
McCarthy started interrupts with New
York Democrat congressman al exam
Acacio Cortez made a pretty explosive
allegation about facilities at the
border let's play her comment and I'll
ask you to respond they put them in with
no running water and these women were
being told by CBP officers to drink out
of the toilet they were drinking water
out of the toilet and that was them
knowing that a congressional visit was
coming that was this is CBP on their
best behavior telling people that drink
out of the toilet what do you make of
that sir
I've wasn't in there I've been to the
border many times I never saw anything
like that that would be unacceptable but
what's very concerning to me is now
they're just coming to the border we've
been trying to get funding humanitarian
aid here and unfortunately that
congresswoman was holding it up she
voted against this age she even voted
against the Democrat vote in the house
just a little bit before so I don't even
know where she stands when it comes to
this issue that's what's concerning to
me alright Leader Kevin McCarthy thanks
so much for your time have a safe
Independence Day break and I'll see you
back on the hill thank you I wish you
all the best